السيد.  الرئيس بسبب هذا
الاعتراف التاريخي ولأنني أعتقد أن
مقالتك الأولى تحقق التوازن الصحيح
حيث وافقت الخطط الأخرى على
التفاوض بشأن السلام مع الفلسطينيين
على أساس خطة السلام الخاصة بك ،
إنها خطة رائعة لإسرائيل ، إنها
خطة عظيمة للسلام  عمليا السيد.
الرئيس ، بالنظر إلى كل ما
فعلته بالفعل لإسرائيل وأفترض
أنك كنت أعظم صديق
لإسرائيل على الإطلاق في البيت الأبيض
بصراحة على الرغم من أن لدينا بعض
الأصدقاء الرائعين في هذه القاعات ، إلا أنه
لم يتم إغلاق خطة السلام الخاصة بك.
الفلسطينيون طريق إلى دولة مستقبلية
أعلم أن الأمر قد يستغرق
وقتًا طويلاً جدًا للوصول إلى نهاية هذا
المسار ، فقد يستغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً جدًا للوصول إلى بداية
هذا المسار ولكن إذا كان الفلسطينيون
مستعدين حقًا  أن يسلكوا هذا المسار إذا
كانوا مستعدين حقًا لعقد
سلام مع الدولة اليهودية وإذا
وافقوا على الالتزام بجميع الشروط التي قدمتها
في خطتك ،
ستكون إسرائيل هناك ستكون
مستعدة للتفاوض على السلام على الفور
[موسيقى]